they even managed to transform the
border fence itself into a percussion
instrument German US and Mexican
musicians performed together in Tijuana
to protest against President Trump's
plan for a new war the man behind the
idea was Marcos rent musical director of
the drezna Symphonica after growing up
in his Germany he said he didn't believe
that walls could work no matter were is
new again DS mejor
it's not just about this wall here but
we are against walls in general against
walls in people's minds we see in the
Europe and other places that nationalism
and extremism are on the rise this was
how our the concert was originally
planned to take place on both sides of
the border US authorities however denied
permission for the event on the US side
citing security concerns Mexico the
German orchestra found a lot of support
even was the consider I don't think
there should be any borders we are all
humans barriers almost in people's minds
mental Alma's principalmente la cultura
y el que se Sepik a no estamos de
acuerdo cultures a good way to unite
people and to deliver a political
message en la que podemos relacionados
de mejor manera manifest Arno's de la
mejor manera
The Dresden Symphonica a non-profit
cultural group are known for not shying
away from controversial projects
[Music]
by performing at the us-mexico border
they say they hope to inspire others it
was a big challenge for the German
musicians to organize this protest
concert here in Tijuana but they
succeeded in spite of many obstacles
with little money but gift for
improvisation they sent a strong message
against not only Donald Trump's plan for
a border wall but against walls all over
the world